warning this game contains scenes of
severe violence and gore if you don't
always review them please close this
game now or else what
hello mister thief take the Hat oh it's
a merciless little kid isn't he hello
everybody my name is Margo lion welcome
to whack the thief you guys really
really really enjoyed whack your boss
and I don't know if that was his pent-up
frustration at your own workplace habits
or if it was another deeper issue that
we're not gonna explore right now so
let's relieve more stress on this
unsuspecting thief I got him it's much
better animating this one than it wasn't
the other one excuse me are you a really
old man robbing my house all righty then
huh the kids like suits they keep coming
into my house Oh at least his turtleneck
kept his stump nice and warm
Oh classy touch all right what else we
got Oh another one more you see what
happens if I wait too long are you gonna
do something are you just gonna stare at
me glaringly yeah all right fine a
player came take this I'm gonna get ya
twitchy about neck things I don't like
it this is so close to Christmas I feel
bad because he he might be Santa Claus
for all I know that's what Santa looks
like and here I go with a dumbbell
again I know that didn't have anything
to do with the dumbbell oh here we go
alrighty then this kid might be a little
bit messed up but that's okay who else
wasn't brutally murder a thief that's
breaking and entering into his own house
yeah
I've added up about to be here to here
to here with you also to you I don't
know what I'm talking about anymore
what he said before dude run away
haven't you had enough old man boy what
is that murder people in so many ways
compared to the boss thing maybe this
guy can no reserve
okay yes play those games kid play them
hard I've only gotten five of 13 how
many more ways could there be
I'll show you little bread wait oh no no
no okay that sounds bad I thought he was
gonna go for the neck that's still bad
Oh dad no not dead oh okay I wonder if
that screwdriver on the grounds a thing
up I finished him off does a good old
sock to the jaw
now the screwdrivers how about this dill
oil oh not dill not gonna kill him with
pickles as far as I know we're gonna
kill them with oil well this just mean
look at him it's like home alone it's so
funny in some ways except for except for
the part where he keeps going yeah
all right it was like almost comical
until he died all right what does the
door do well did you know there is hell
house is haunted hey hey why is he
trying to whisper yell who's he afraid
of waking up it's someone whisper
yelling into a microphone hello one
chance hi guys I think it's a shovel
maybe it's a rake oh it's a golf club
okay
oh you miss try again
yep Joe's got a little Slugger you'll
get in a min keep going
alright okay alright you're not cut out
for golf okay
Oh tackle box is that a toolbox tackle
tool but toolbox
the obvious Reverend stays venture movie
don't recall the poor we die horribly
alrighty then there you have it so look
into the dead eyes of this kid watch him
as he plays his cane watch him as he is
emotionless knowing full well what he
just did
or whatever what about flashlight of
course how would I possibly miss that
one nothing to do with the flashlight
okay that this kid is very good at
killing man there's got to be like some
stories behind this kid like some origin
stories of comics made about this kid
what he's done to get to this point I
didn't think I did this
hey did I do that I don't know if I know
I don't think I did that get in the bag
look boy I was a mistake in the bag
yeah just for good measure in case the
Cobra wasn't gonna finish him off yeah
that yeah that use your full body weight
on it he'll stop twitching eventually
bought a book book book get book books
are for learning books are for nerds Oh
Matt it's not a book he was an old man
the old man cowering oh good there's
nothing left
we're at the epilogue kids just bored
whatever homework whatever dad for video
games I guess so oh man well that's all
the whack the thief there is there's
other whacked the whatever games that I
could play if you really want me to play
him it's more just like a storybook and
you just see me cringing it's a
different death but hey if that's what
you want me to do let me know in the
comments below thanks again everybody
for watching check out the other videos
I did about wacky or whatever's in the
description below or the annotations
over there thanks again everybody and as
always I will see you in the next video
how's about to say those legal but shows
the murdering thief